what else you do this weekend you saw a
football game yeah I went to the went to
the UT yeah so we surfed in Waco which
was really [ __ ] cool yeah uh we
surfed there on Thursday night slept
over there then surfed on Friday morning
nice so we got like a million waves yeah
place is amazing and then went golfing
went to the UT game which sucked
what
as soon as you said a million waves I
checked out
why dude
we went to Waco which also tragedy don't
know if you remember that I was just
waiting all right but then you're like
gotten some waves then guess what we
woke up and we got some waves in the
morning a million of them it's sick
was that your bachelor party yeah okay
that's a cool cool thing I think I
thought so for a surfer um
it'd be like you know what's up what's
beneath the
surf pool what there's a bunch of dead
kids beneath that surf pool did that
happen there
[Laughter]
I mean what you know some real estate
developer that land like went [ __ ]
minus 30 and he was like oh easy yeah
yeah he's just like his costs how much
yeah yeah just ran his card yeah through
the square wreath a nice little American
Express just swipe yeah yeah
he's like what are you gonna do with it
a horror would say we're gonna put a
surf wrench so it was your bachelor
party but did you so how many strippers
did you get and all that stuff Etc no
strippers um
yeah my friends really did me dirty on
that one if if one of your friends
actually would have gone to stripper
would you have been pissed
pissed are you that kind of guy yeah no
I would have been pissed so you're not
faithful to your wife
you walk walked right into it that was a
doorway you walked in yeah sorry I would
have been Furious actually see that's
what I was wanting yes
have you been do you go to strip clubs
I've been to a woman took me on a date
to a strip club when I was uh 21. really
she took you there yeah yeah I was gonna
say your mom yeah my mom I'm like we're
swinging in what do you want for your
birthday I want to see big titties and
[ __ ] I didn't actually think that at
the at the strip club I had no idea so I
was like [ __ ] let's go because we had
been drinking and she's like let's just
go and I was like okay
I always went in there and I sued
bro Kansas City strip club on like a
Tuesday night are you kidding me this
one comes out comes out to [ __ ]
hinders Lips of an Angel which guess
what
saw full beave and everything yeah it
did not care for it I was like as soon
as I saw that I was like oh my God I
thought that it was just boobies
right they dance around you weren't
coming for it no or was she the one not
caring for it I think that she's having
fun because I don't know
I'm sure if she was like crying on stage
but we have to leave no that's her job
you know she's she's making money
whatever but it was just so the the the
sound speakers like on the stage and
then it's just like a room full of men
looking at a it's just odd yeah so odd
everyone like all the old men in there
are just like
like glaring up on
this kind of face and I was like we
should leave
why are we here I'm sorry I just thought
about you you said full beam you just
look at her Bush he just started getting
flashbacks hearing your dad in the
background
[Laughter]
my name's Hunter get that goddamn paper
I don't know it was it was it was weird
[Music]
it was uh
it wasn't good and then also I don't
like being touched so every time
somebody came by they're like do you
want to dance
that kind of thing yeah you ever see
that South Park my legs are kind of
sweaty I apologize you ever see that
South Park bit where it's like they're
in the the strip club and the woman
comes over she's like do you want to
dance
is that it's just true they keep
touching me I'm like I drifted no thanks
yeah I don't like that the whole time
yeah yeah it's like being in the perfume
section of like uh a mall yeah like a
JCPenney with like yeah you'd like run
around it it's gonna do that
unprompted do they oh yes oh they don't
give a [ __ ] yeah they're trying to
deplete that bottle I don't think they
can get off work until the bottle's gone
yeah hey how you doing hey yeah you'll
walk by what are you doing they'll walk
by and they'll just like that's black
pearl and you're like just okay yeah
you're just
that's black pearl and your vision goes
blurry
yeah walk around
the first strip club I ever went to was
in Canada it was in London Ontario
and so I think most places in Canada
they don't get fully nude but in Ontario
they do and the thing is is that we
don't have dollar bills
we have dollar coins
so traditionally at a strip club you
throw dollar bills or you put them in
you know the thing or whatever like the
bra
in this case it was just you she
one of the girls got up and again full
beef and the task was to you you're
supposed to throw the coins
at the beef
so so wishing well yes and this is we're
talking Looney's antoons and toonies yes
damn I just pictured her walking around
naked but she has like a strap from one
of those old school like arcade yeah
yeah like manager yeah yeah like yeah
she's like thank you
[Laughter]
that would be probably the most
convenient like it would look stupid but
that would probably be the fastest way
yeah because like what I mean like what
like did she just have like a [ __ ]
Sack or did she actually have to go
through individually and hold like a
stack of coins and like walk off stage
yeah I think you have to like collect
them and then grab them and it's [ __ ]
up it was rough especially if your nails
aren't wrong enough and you're kind of
like picking up that corner sorry my
nails aren't wrong and you're like you
have to kind of it's a struggle to get
the coins up yeah yeah
actually what would be your stripper
song uh J's On My Feet
juicy wow this is the throwback
I've actually I've thought about this
quite a bit and I think it would be
a long way back from Hell by Danzig
let me say a song that you guys probably
know
uh uh I would do Faithfully Journey
Highway run
into the to say that the road ain't no
place to start a family
remember that nope
uh
uh how about I would do Back in Black
okay I know that song I'd be one of
those people where you're just like okay
you know he's getting it yeah right
and you're like [ __ ] um
and they're like the foundation of this
building is so strong
and it gives all the other girls and
boys confidence to go out there and you
know do their thing I yeah I'm a uh what
is it was it I take charge
this is what they call it what I want
what I want to say what torch bear I'm a
flag Runner I don't even know yeah I
can't remember words yeah Trailblazer
Trailblazer I'm a Trailblazer I give
everybody the confidence to just be
themselves what would yours be I don't
know I've never I'm still thinking about
it I've never thought about this what
about West Side gun would you come out
to him
I have no idea what that is oh my god
dude lost on me God damn I think it's I
think that's a form of respect to come
out to someone yes I think as a yes got
it because what about D4L Laffy Taffy I
mean oh yeah the extent of my rap
knowledge is about 2006. all right and
that's whenever I was like I went into
other so like Bubba Sparks yeah yeah
okay lately
yeah isn't he like a youth pastor or
something like that or I guess he's not
used to have to be a pastor he's a clean
cut now he's ripped is it yeah can we
get a current picture of Bubba Sparks
doesn't he also do like religious music
now I think he might I definitely think
there's like a religious angle to it
yeah which is unfortunate yes
um kind of like the older fatter version
of it no put Bubba Sparks now look at
him with Ed Sheeran bottom row all the
way to the right yeah it looks like a
military recruiter yeah look at that all
the way to the right top row he's like
have you ever thought about Joy the
National Guard wow clean cut yeah and
then Ed Sheeran yeah no when your legs
down
he's like you know there's a lot of
veterans that can relate to that song
it's true
I think you should come out to the
Afghanistan Afghan base in Afghanistan
and uh sing a tune or two for the boys
Ed Sheeran's been can you say that again
that's how people from the South Sound
to me it's true they also only Porky Pig
to you yeah